[MUSIC PLAYING]
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Welcome to Cloud on Air
live webinars from Google
Cloud, and this is CE TV.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Yuri Grinshteyn.
I'm a Cloud customer
engineer here at Google,
and today joined by Spoons, the
CTO and co-founder of LightStep
to talk about observability
and distributed applications.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have folks on standby
ready to answer them.
So let's get started.
So first of all,
Spoons, thank you
so much for being here today.
We appreciate it.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, my pleasure.
It's great to be here.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right.
So let's talk about
microservices.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Sure.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: I
think a lot of folks
think of them as kind of
the ultimate answer to all
of their problems.
What do you think?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, there's a lot
of great things about
microservices, serverless,
other sort of modern
architectures.
I think it lets you scale.
It lets you divide the work
among your team in a lot
of ways, so yeah it's great.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, but I'm assuming
that we wouldn't be here
today if it were perfect.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: That's right.
I think as much as
that microservices
help you move quickly,
you kind of often
lose the big picture
for what's actually
happening in your application.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, and I think
one of the ways you lose it--
sort of one of the issues
you have is around
observability, right?
And the more services
you have, the more stuff
you have talking to each
other-- the harder it is
to understand what's going on.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
especially if you kind of step
back and think of it from
your users' point of view.
Users don't care how many
microservices are involved.
They just care about the
experience they have,
and that's going to cut across
all of your services in a way
that maybe your
traditional tools are not
taking into account.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, so what
are some of the observability
challenges that you've seen with
microservices architectures?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, I think it really
starts from just the
tools themselves,
so I think when you think about
what's happening-- you know,
we saw this tweet that
I think is pretty funny.
"I replaced our monolith
with microservices,
and that turns every outage
into a murder mystery."
That's really kind of
coming from the fact
that people kind of look at
these three tools in terms--
or three sets of tools-- of
how they look at observability.
Metrics, logging,
and tracing are
sort of three approaches to how
you might see what's going on
inside the application itself.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So let's
talk about those three.
So first, metrics, right?
They're time series data,
what are they useful for?
What do they tell us
about what's happening
within our application?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, metrics are
great for understanding when
something has gone wrong.
It's easy to set thresholds,
alerts, things like that.
You can get notified.
They're not so great
about understanding
why something's gone wrong.
So you know it's easy to tell
that it might be correlated
failures, but understanding
the causes of failures
can be pretty hard.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right.
So yeah, I think it's a good
way of describing it right.
Metrics tell us when
something happens.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So how do we
find out what is happening?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So again,
traditionally, maybe you
look at a logging tool to
do something like that.
Logging is great about
giving a ton of detail
about a specific
transaction or maybe
within a specific
service, and yeah it
can give you that detail.
I think the downside of it
is really the volume of data
that you might have there.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Sure.
All right, so we got
metrics, and we've got logs.
What about traces?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Traces are good.
It's sort of the new
kid on the block,
I feel like, in
this in some ways.
One of my co-founders
built a system at Google
called Dapper, which was
Google's distributed tracing
system.
And Dapper was great
for understanding
the latency and some
of the other issues
that were coming up
in Google's web search
and able to really,
like, identify,
for a particular search,
where was the latency?
Where was the
slowness coming from?
You do a search as a user--
you don't think about it,
but there is web docs, there's
news, there's personal results,
there's images.
There's all kinds of things that
are sort of feeding into that.
Any one of those things could
be a problem at any time.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Sure.
All right, so we've
got our metrics
to tell us what is going on.
We've got logs that
allow us to understand
errors and specific events.
We got traces that tell
us what our latency is,
and then we have
distributed tracing,
which kind of tells
us what's the latency
between different microservices.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yep.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
All right, so why
is observability
still a problem?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes,
so each of these things
has kind of their own
problems in a way,
so really to take
advantage of metrics
you want to be able to dig
in a bit and understand
is this problem only occurring
in the latest releases
or incurred in all releases?
OK, well, how do
I do that, right?
I tag it, right?
I put a tag on
the data, so now I
can sort of segment
by different releases.
I probably also want to segment
maybe by host or data center,
so I can figure out if there's
some sort of infrastructure
problem.
A lot of folks,
us included, we'll
tag based upon customer IDs, but
these things start adding up--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of customers.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes, exactly.
And when you think about the way
that a metrics tool is built,
it really has to keep
track of every one
of these individual streams--
and really, the
kind of full cross
product of all those things--
every different combination.
And this is what
folks kind of refer
to as sort of the cardinality
problem, in a sense.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Sure, all right.
So metrics are good,
because they tell us
when things are happening.
But it's hard to
keep track of them,
especially if you've
got a big system--
lots of services, lots of
customers, lots of metrics.
All right.
Well, surely logs don't
have any problems.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
they might have a few.
So logs are great,
but you really
end up paying by volume
a lot of the time.
And if the amount of logging
that you're generating
is just proportional to
the amount of service
that you're providing-- cool,
that's just like fixed costs.
It's no problem.
You can think about that.
But as the complexity
or service grows,
and you start building
out similar microservices
or similar architecture,
you're going
to want to add more logging
for each new microservice
that you add.
So now the amount of logging
that you're generating
is not just proportional
to the traffic
that you're serving
to your users
but also to the complexity
of what you're building.
And that means either your
costs are going to go way up,
or if you fix your
costs you're going
to have to reduce the amount
of logging that you do.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So you have to
look at things like sampling.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yes, or even just--
I know folks that won't
log in some environments.
Like, they just don't log in
their staging environment,
because it's too expensive.
That's unfortunate,
because, you know,
that could be really valuable
in diagnosing problems
in that environment.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: It's hard
to reproduce a problem
outside of production if you
don't have logging turned on
in those environments.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right,
so logs don't necessarily
scale as well.
All right, let's
talk about traces.
What are the issues there?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
Yeah, so at least in the way
traces were built in Google
and the way that they
are built in Dapper
is they were actually looking at
a pretty narrow problem, which
is looking at--
for a web search,
how do we understand
overall latency?
And it turns out that
Google does, like,
a bazillion requests
every second,
and so you can actually
throw away a lot of the data
and still get a
pretty good signal.
And so, for Dapper
actually, the costs
were not in terms of the
overhead in the application
itself, so that is, like,
in web search Google still,
I think anyway, basically
doing instrumentation
every request that comes in.
The thing that turns
out to be expensive
is actually just storing
all of that data.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Oh
yeah, that makes sense.
I could see how that
could be a lot of data.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, so within Dapper,
kind of the default mode
anyway is that you throw out
99.9% of the data
almost immediately,
and then you throw
out another 90%.
So you're down to
99.99% of the data as
thrown out, so you just have
this tiny fraction of what's
left.
And again, like, 0.1% of a
bazillion is still like--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: It's a lot.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
--a big number.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
But now you start
to miss out on some of the
finer detail, where it's like,
OK, well, if you're just
looking in aggregate across all
of Google's [INAUDIBLE], great.
But if we want to start talking
about maybe a different use
case, where you've got
these interesting segments
of different customers.
You're interested in
sort of a small fraction
of your customers.
The chances of that small
fraction overlapping
with this 0.1% are
starting to get small.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, so I
can see some of the challenges
that we're trying
to identify, right.
It's hard to keep track of
lots of different metrics.
It's hard to keep all
of the logs just because
of the amount of data we have
to store, and how much it costs.
You know, whether you're
paying your infrastructure
costs to yourself
in your data center
or to someone like Google to
store them, it's still a lot.
And then traces also create
a lot of data, is that right?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
So I think you actually
hit it right there.
I mean, the way that we kind of
think about these at LightStep
is that metrics, logs,
and traces are just data.
And as much as that
people kind of in the past
have thought about it
as three separate tools
that you've got
in your tool belt,
there's a lot of opportunities
to really look at
where you can use them
to interact and leverage
aspects of metrics, and
how you do log collection--
look at how log
collection-- or how logs
can be combined with traces.
And that way, you can sort of
look more holistically at what
are the problems
that we're actually
trying to solve as an
observability tool?
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
So now what I feel
like I'm the person in
the infomercial, who's
like struggling.
I'm, like, dropping things, or
I'm trying to chop vegetables.
I don't know what I'm doing.
And then the announcer
comes on and says,
you know, surely, there
must be a better way?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: There
is a knife for that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right, so
tell me about the better way.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Sure.
So let's just do
kind of a quick demo.
So this is sort of one view into
what we can show in LightStep,
so this is kind of a demo
app that we've put together.
So what we're doing is we're
monitoring application here,
which does some sort
of reservation system.
I don't know if it's cars, or
seats, or tickets, or something
like that.
But anyway, there's an app.
There's a bunch of
microservices on the back end.
And what we can
do is we can look
at it across a bunch of
different dimensions,
so here we're looking at a
particular set of requests that
are coming from the iOS app.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Things
look pretty flat, right?
Everything seems to be
consistent and fine here?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes,
so sort of three parts
of what we're doing on the
top-- looking at latency, which
is sort of the
slowness-- how long it's
taking to respond to requests.
Below that, the
rate of requests--
and then below that,
the error rate.
So rate's pretty steady.
No errors are happening,
so that's all good.
And looking at latency,
yeah, it's pretty flat.
What we're doing here
is we're only showing,
though, the median latency.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
So that's basically
sort for 50 percentile
on what we're doing.
If we sort of step
back a little bit,
we can actually, in
LightStep, look not just
at the 50th percentile
but look at these higher
percentiles above that.
So we can look at 95th
percentile, 99th percentile,
or even 99.9th percentile.
When we look at those
actually, there's
a lot more story to tell
about what's going on here.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yes,
so this is actually
showing you a very
different picture, right?
Even though our median
latency is very flat,
and there's really
nothing happening there.
When we start going to
the high percentiles,
it really looks like
there was an event here.
There was a latency spike, then
latency sort of almost crashed,
and then it evened down back
to kind of its expected value.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So that's
a very different picture
that you get when you look
at those higher percentiles
than what you get when you're
just looking at the median.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, and that's I
think super important,
especially in a distributed
system.
One of the reasons is that
these high percentile latencies,
they are often
sort of bellwethers
for what's going to happen for
most of your users later on.
So these are really
users that are
kind of pushing the
envelope, in a way,
and as your overall
traffic grows,
hopefully, it's not just
going to be 1% of users
that are experiencing that.
It's going to be more, but
if he can get ahead of it
and fix it for those 1% before
it becomes a wider spread
problem, that's great.
The second thing is when you're
building a distributed system,
you know, we're really just
looking at one component here.
And we're looking and seeing
that 1% of the requests
to that particular
component are slow,
but if you think about it
from a user's perspective
their transaction,
their request,
is going to hit a whole
bunch of different services.
So if each of those
has 1% that's low,
the chances that
a user is actually
having a bad experience are
going to go up, and up, and up.
So maybe in an individual
service it's only 1%
of requests, but,
you know, if there's
20 services you know it's going
to be 20% of requests that are
going to be slow for the user.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right,
so next obvious question--
I know that we're having
some latency issues.
Why?
What's going on?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, so I think--
I kind of think of the
latency measurements
that LightStep does is kind
of table stakes in a way.
Like, you just got to do this.
I think one of the cool things
that LightStep adds on top
is that we're
actually also keeping
a record of transactions
across these differently,
and it's actually using the
latency as a kind of signal
to tell what might be an
interesting transaction
to go look at.
So each of these
little dots here
represents some transaction,
where we've captured
a complete trace for that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, so
that's a lot of traces.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, I mean, we
pick what we think is a kind
of representative sample.
We don't expect a human
to look at all of these.
The way that I
kind of think of it
is like, sort of, automated
crime scene investigations.
So, you know, you're
the detective.
You know that
something's gone wrong.
You've got this robot that'll
come in and do this like--
you know, both-- you
know, get good coverage
kind of evidence
gathering but also
be a little bit intelligent.
It's not going to help you to
get, like, 10,000 fingerprints
if all you is 10, right?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Right, you
want the important ones.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
In this, we actually
try to bias.
Like, if we were just
picking sort of arbitrarily,
most of them would be
down here at the bottom.
In fact, half of them would
be below the bottom line.
We actually biased
towards these longer ones,
so even though these requests
way up kind at the top here
represent, say, only 0.01%,
0.05% of the requests,
we're going to capture those
more frequently than that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, so tell
me more about that biasing,
because that sounds like
something very different
than I've seen other
monitoring tools do.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah, it's a
little bit tricky to get right,
and it's actually kind
of feeds into the built
about the way we built it.
But really, the idea
is that you want
to understand as much about
the transaction as possible
before you decide
whether or not it's
going to be something
that a human's going
to want to look at.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Sure,
that makes sense.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: And slowness
is a great signal to use.
Unfortunately, you don't
know if a request is slow
until it's done.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's right.
And you need to be
capturing the trace as it's
happening, that way it's done.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly,
so there's a kind of time
travel that we have to
do to make that happen,
and this is pretty different
than the way you have your--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So you've
finally-- you did it?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah, in
a pretty narrow case but we
got a kind of time travel.
The way Dapper kind
of took this approach
is that-- like again,
there's a bazillion requests.
They're all kind of the same.
It doesn't matter which.
They actually made this decision
right when the request started,
and we make it at the end.
Or even, it can be seconds or
minutes after the request ends,
so where there's something
else that's interesting
that we think is sort of
relevant to a human trying
to debug what's going on.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, so cool.
So now show me what-- what
are we seeing when we're
capturing these transactions?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yes, so let me dig in
on one of these things.
This is a request that
took about seven seconds,
and we're showing
kind of a trace
of-- we can think of it
like kind of a Gantt chart,
or we've got Chrome Debugger
or something like that.
At the top, what we have is
sort of a summary of what's
going on, breaking down
each of the services
in a different color.
And just looking
pretty quickly at this,
I can tell this
purple service here,
that's really the bottleneck.
That's what's taking-- it looks
like more than five seconds
of this request, so if I click
into that, that gets more data.
I can see this is in--
this is an API server.
It's doing something
called userspace mapping,
and now if I want to see
why that's happening,
well I've got a bunch
of additional detail.
I've got some tags, and I've got
some logs that are associated
with this particular request.
And I can see this
is because we're
doing some sort of
connection pooling.
Pool is exhausted.
We stalled.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
it's really valuable
to have this information sort of
all in the same context, right?
You've got the trace.
For the service, it's telling
you how long things took,
but then you're
pulling in the log
data that's telling you exactly
why it took as long as it did.
In this case, it's because--
yeah, we're out of connections.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, exactly.
So this kind of gets
to what we think
is the two kind of fundamental
activities in this.
One is measurement--
understanding
when something is happening, or
when something has gone wrong.
And the other is
explaining what's
happening and being
able to get to the root
causes of those things.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So one other
thing you may need to do
is to understand--
all right, so we
knew that when we capture this
trace, here was the problem.
How representative is
this of everything else
that's going on?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, exactly.
Like, is this still
happening, right?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
One of the things--
you know, we have this kind
of time travel, in a sense.
What we can do is we can
look at all the requests
for this particular
service that occurred
over, say, the last
five or 10 minutes,
and then we can kind
of break that down.
Here we're showing a
histogram, not a time series,
so this is trying to sort
of plot that population.
And you can kind of see there's
a kind of a funny shape here.
It's not totally smooth.
It looks like there's sort of
maybe two distinct things that
are happening, based
upon that shape,
so what I can do is
I can kind of filter,
look at some of those--
I can compare to what
it looked like before.
Maybe the shape changed a
little bit over the last hour.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
That's really useful.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
And now I've got
a bunch of examples of these
kinds of transactions that
have occurred recently
in the last minute or so,
and I can get a quick summary
of what the problems here
might be.
Again, it looks like
this userspace mapping
thing is still a problem for
these slower transactions.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All
right, very cool.
So this looks great.
Obviously, it takes a lot of
data and a lot of processing
to make all this happen.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So how does
LightStep actually work?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
So we've got, kind
of logically anyway,
what we think of as a
hybrid architecture.
Certainly, part of LightStep
is a SaaS tool, but part of it
also is an on-prem component.
So we call that on-prem the
satellites, and the satellites
are really gathering data from
all kinds of different sources.
It could be from
your microservices.
It could be that we patched
in with your monolith,
because you probably
still have one of those.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: A couple.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Everyone
still has at least one.
And we've even patched in with
other logging tools and things
like that, as well as
gathering data from clients,
and all of that data
goes to the satellites.
So this is where we
were a little bit
different than
something like Dapper,
where even at that point
within the application itself,
some sampling was
already happening,
for LightStep all of this
data gets to the satellites.
So the satellites are getting
this crazy fire hose of data,
and they're holding onto it just
for a few minutes-- basically
long enough for us, by
coordinating through the SaaS
side of things, to understand
whether or not there's
anything interesting there.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK,
so tell me what's
happening once the satellites
kind of do their magic-- they
send the data to the cloud?
What's happening there?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So a couple
of things-- one was we're
collecting these statistics,
so we can do things
like show you p99.
The other thing that we're
doing is sending requests
back to the satellites
actually, so it's
sort of a
bi-directional protocol
that we do because it
might not be that something
was interesting in itself.
It was actually
perfectly fine, but it
provides important
context for understanding
why something else was slow.
And we sort of-- you can
think of the satellites
as kind of an online
stream processing system.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK,
that makes sense.
All right, so then the
next logical question is--
the SaaS, the cloud component,
is built on Google Cloud?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
That's right, yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
How did you do that?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: I kind
of think about, you know,
where we want to put our
time, as a kind of engineering
organization?
Where do we want to use
things off the shelf that
are meeting our needs?
And where do we need to add
our own kind of special sauce?
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
That makes sense.
So I see you've got
Kubernetes on here.
You've got Cloud SQL
and Spanner as well.
So I'm really interested
in all of these.
Let's talk about
Kubernetes first.
Obviously, this is something
that lots and lots of folks
are interested in.
Like, everyone is building
stuff on Kubernetes.
Tell me about-- how did you
arrive at kind of building
things on Kubernetes.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: If you
kind of go way, way, way
back to kind of the very
beginning of LightStep,
you know, we--
we had our monolith
from the beginning.
We didn't start with
anything too fancy.
We had a little
bash shell script
that we used to do
deployments, and eventually
that shell script became
not such a little shell
script anymore.
They only put the first
few lines on here.
The rest of it is a
little bit embarrassing,
but we've got to a point where--
like, I was just, you know--
it was getting--
there's too many ways
to fail, too many ways--
you know, I don't want to test
for this kind of thing, right?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's right.
Anything you're using in
production should be tested,
and when you're having to write
tests for your shell scripts
then you're in a tough place.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
not the right place.
So the way I was kind of
thinking about it at that time
is I wanted to kind
of leap frog ahead.
Like, I didn't want to skip.
You know, I don't want to date
myself by saying, you know,
where I think shell
scripts come from exactly,
but, you know, I didn't
want to skip to, like, 2004
or anything like that.
I wanted to skip right
to whatever, 2016, 2017.
And so, for me,
that wasn't-- like,
let's kind of set a lot of
this sort of configuration
management aside and just go
straight to something like
Kubernetes.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So how did
you end up deploying Kubernetes
in production?
Did you end up using,
like, one big cluster?
Did you have lots
of smaller clusters?
How did you make
those decisions?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: In several
times maybe, over and over,
but I mean we started with one.
I guess, obviously that's
where you always start.
I think we thought about
building out a bunch of them
at some point.
Where I kind of arrived-- as
I think it's nice to have two,
in a lot of ways.
As much as I like--
so we use Container Engine.
The container engine
automates a lot of things,
and, you, know runs the master.
And like, I'm super happy that
someone else is monitoring
that kind of thing for me,
but there is-- you know,
you still have to
understand what's going on.
Node upgrades are super
easy, but someone's still
got to do it and
click that button.
So I didn't really want
to be in a state, where,
like, every engineer was
managing their own Kubernetes
cluster.
That was too many.
On the other hand, I
like having a couple,
so that we can test out a new
node version, things like that,
in a non-customer
facing environment.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
So you basically
have one call-like task and
then one production cluster
kind of thing?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Roughly, yeah.
I mean, the test one's used
for a lot of things, not
just load testing and
integration testing.
It's used for a bunch
of developer things.
You know, if other
folks in the company
want to play with stuff,
they can do it there.
It let's us keep that
thing pretty open
as well, because there's
no customer data in that.
So it's like if you want
to play with it, go ahead.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So given
that your infrastructure is
relatively straightforward,
how did you
end up splitting the team
and the responsibilities
to do things like--
even that one cluster,
where you said it still
requires management,
right-- someone has
to decide to operate the nose,
versus someone else says,
OK, here is the code
that we're pushing.
So how did you end up, like,
divvying up those roles?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So we
have certainly some experts
in these kinds of
things, who are
kind of keeping track
of that, and are
aware of when we need to do
upgrades and things like that,
and probably handle
a lot of that.
But I didn't really want to
create a team, whose job was
just to do that, in a sense.
Like, maybe when we're bigger--
when we get to the scale
of other companies,
we'll have to do that kind
of thing, but to me-- like,
I wanted to keep DevOps or SRE
to be a super collaborative
kind of engagement.
And that means that, like,
our SREs are actually
sort of embedded in teams and
do some small amounts of product
development work
as part of that,
and I think that
actually helps them build
a lot of empathy
for their customers
with other engineers
at LightStep.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
that makes sense.
Right.
When you're responsible
for supporting this thing,
but you've also been the
one to figure out what
push to production.
You're operating on the
same SLAs and error budgets,
and shared empathy
is super important.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, very cool.
Now let's talk
about the back end.
You've got a lot of data
coming into the system.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: That's right.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Where is it going?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
that's the hard part, I think.
If you don't have
persistence, like, everything
is pretty easy, right?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Right.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So I mean,
there's some stories in this,
I think.
Back in the day when LightStep
was just a demo and just
a pilot, we started just
developing from our laptops.
And so, we were
running MySQL locally.
It's pretty easy.
And we put a ton
of data in there--
probably some data that
shouldn't have been there,
but it was a demo, right?
So you're just moving fast.
I think this is the thing
that always kind of like--
not haunts me but
I think back about.
Like, we've been
kind of continuously
operating LightStep from those
very early pilot days, and--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: I mean, that's
really fairly common, right?
In startups, you often come out
of something like a hackathon.
You've got this thing
that you built overnight,
and suddenly you're doing, you
know, sales calls to customers
and going in production.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
Part of me-- you know,
the engineer deep inside
wants to, like, make a clean
start, and start on B2,
and things like that.
But I just-- you
know, there's no time,
and it's probably not
the right thing anyway.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: It's
never the right time
to start from scratch.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So a lot
of the stuff is in MySQL--
definitely some things
that shouldn't be.
One of those was a bunch
of time series data--
not super high frequency but,
like, still time series data
itself.
And when we moved into
Cloud, we were really
starting to overwhelm the
Cloud SQL servers with just
the write rate, and keeping
up with replication,
and things like that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
So it's interesting that
you bring up time series
and write rate,
because whenever I
talk to customers that have
that particular problem
in their environment, I
would say, hey, Bigtable
was built to do just that.
And you've got it
on your slide here,
so you were kind of
doing my pitch for me.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
We actually took
kind of a long path
through these, which
maybe not totally evident.
And so, we actually
moved to Cassandra first.
This was actually before
Bigtable was a product,
so that was sort of
where we were first
feeling the pain around this.
And Cassandra was great in a
lot of ways, though I think--
in retrospect, I never want
to sort of underestimate
the amount of expertise that's
required to run a distributed
storage system.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
that makes sense.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: So we
actually got into a pretty bad
state with Cassandra.
So we run a couple of
different environments.
One of them we
call Meta, which is
the LightStep environment that
monitors the other LightStep
environments.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK,
that sounds important.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, for us it's
important to understand.
Our customers depend on
us to be up and understand
their systems.
We've got to be available.
So the Cassandra
cluster that we were
running as part of the Meta
environment got into a state
where one of the
nodes was corrupted,
and we had not done a great job
with some of the configuration.
And it was basically going to
be a significant outage for us
to recover that thing,
and that, again,
a non-customer
facing environment.
So we could make it work.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Probably not
a pattern you'd want to be in.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, exactly.
I didn't-- you know, what
was going to stop this from
happening [INAUDIBLE],, so we
actually wanted to move pretty
quickly to get out of that state
and migrate our data elsewhere.
We actually did some
evaluation of Bigtable
and of Spanner at that
point and kind of looked at
like, you know, what are
the costs going to be?
What are the, sort of, overhead
in terms of the latency
that that's going to
introduce into our product,
and what are the kind
of different features
that are available
on those things?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So I actually
want to come back to Spanner,
but tell me more
about that evaluation.
So how did you do it,
and what did you see?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
We actually used
LightStep itself to do some
of that evaluation, which
is pretty fun.
So this is just showing latency
for the reads against Cassandra
and against Spanner.
The Bigtable ones-- we ended
up reproducing some of this
actually-- looked fairly
similar to the Cassandra one.
[? And ?] a lot of this is
maybe not super surprisingly--
but yeah, I think
this kind of gets
back to what we were
talking about before-- about
the difference between
p50 and p99 latency.
If you look at the
median latency,
Cassandra is a
little bit faster,
which is sort of expected.
It's in the same cluster.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
it's not surprising.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: And
so, it was looking--
median was about 2 and
1/2 to 2 milliseconds.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
That's pretty fast.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
it was great and cool.
Spanner's a little bit slower--
about 6 or 7 milliseconds.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Still pretty fast.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Still
pretty fast, totally within
bounds for what we needed
in terms of our application
in the performance
[? feed. ?] But if you
look at those
longer-tailed latencies,
actually there is
this huge spread
kind of shown in the
graph here by the distance
between the lines on
the Cassandra side.
That p99 latency was two
orders of magnitude bigger.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's a
pretty big distribution.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, so 1% of them
were actually 250 milliseconds.
On the Spanner side,
it's incredibly tight.
So Spanner had this really
predictable behavior,
and to us that was kind
of a comforting thing.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, I think--
the decision you made right.
It's better to be slightly
slower but completely
predictably so than a bit faster
but much less predictable.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, and there
were some other features around
kind of that replication that
were available at Spanner, at
the time anyway, that were also
pretty attractive to us.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right,
so let's go back a step,
because one of the things
I'm really interested in
is kind of how you were
using Spanner, right?
This is a conversation
that I have with customers,
pretty frequently,
that basically
think that Spanner
is basically kind
of the next relational database.
And so if I'm in something like
Cloud SQL today, then Spanner--
you know, once I get to a
certain size, Spanner's just
sort of the logical
next step, right?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And they just
think of it as-- it's a big,
sort of globally consistent
relational database,
but the thing they really care
about is that it's just a--
it's like a fully manageable
relational database.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Exactly, yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And then
you have different customers
or different use cases, where
what they really care about
is that global consistency.
That's absolutely
what they need,
and the only way you get
that, [? certainly, ?] in GCP
is on Spanner.
And that [? would ?] be the only
[? thing ?] given in the world,
[? quite honestly. ?]
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Where
did you kind of end up?
How did you make your
decision to go to Spanner?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: It was kind
of a mix of those, I think.
So part of it was we were
being a bit reactive.
We know we had this cluster
that could fail at any moment.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: You
needed to do something.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes, so
we needed to do something,
and I think Spanner
had the flexibility
to make that
migration pretty easy.
I think for all these
things, you know,
LightStep is going
to change a lot.
We're going to build some
new cool stuff in the future.
Google Cloud is going to offer a
lot of cool stuff in the future
too.
We're going to make more
migrations, and so to me
the thing that was really
attractive about Spanner--
I guess, part of it was the
kind of global replication.
And that made us feel good
about not having the data
wherever we needed it--
but really putting us
in control in terms
of when we were going
to have to migrate again
and knowing that it was going
to scale to whatever we needed.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, it's much better
to do the migration when
you think you're ready
rather than when your
infrastructure says.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
So we can plan-- you
know, this quarter, we're
going to do feature, or
we're going to do migration.
No, we're going to push
the migration off to p1
and be comfortable
knowing that solution's
going to scale to that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All
right, very cool.
All right, so we've
talked about-- you know,
actually, I think I want to ask
one more question that I forgot
to ask about on the
Kubernetes, and I
don't know if you want
to get into this now.
Can you tell me a little about
how you doing multi-tenancy
in Kubernetes?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, it's a mix.
So we have some things,
where we do shared tenancy,
where there's relatively
low overhead in terms of--
well, maybe not low
overhead but just,
like, low computational costs
of what we needed to do.
And we also have cases,
where we want to more--
isolation-- and we
use a combination
of labels and some tainting
to make that happen.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
All right, so we're starting to
get kind of near the end here.
This is a lot of
really good stuff here.
I think you've learned some
really interesting, really
important lessons as you kind
of first got into the Cloud
and then kind of made
some technology changes
and technology migrations.
You know, if you were to
leave our audience with just
a couple of things
that you think
they should learn from your
experience, what would it be?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yes,
so I think one of them
you were asking about a bit.
Like, what was the kind
of cluster architecture
that we set up?
I really like, for
all of these kinds
of questions, the number two,
because one's probably not
enough.
It doesn't give you a
chance to test things out.
10 or 20 is probably a lot.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
It's getting back
to what you're
talking about, where
you don't want every
engineer to have
to manage their own cluster.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
But I think going back,
there's some things
that I might have thought
a little bit harder about,
and I would encourage
other people
to do-- in thinking
about how are you
going to be able to attribute
these infrastructure
costs to your customers?
Is that something that
is interesting to you?
I bet that's going to be
interesting to your CFO
someday--
thinking about how you're
breaking up billing in terms
of where are you spending
money on customer facing
environments, and where are you
spending money on a load test?
And just being able to
understand that over time
is really important.
I think that's influenced
some of our decisions
around Kubernetes, but also
in the storage itself--
when do you create
a new instance?
When do you make a new bucket?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
that makes sense.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
The other thing
I was thinking about
a bit, and something
I would like to continue to
do better for us even is just
kind of step back and think
about that big picture
around storage.
Like, I've sort of
described in terms
of how we got to Spanner--
like, that code followed
this path from MySQL to
Cassandra and eventually
to Spanner.
And you know, there's
a legacy there,
in a sense that we've-- that
code was originally written
with a very different
set of constraints.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's right.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: And
I think if you were
going to be at a point where--
you're going to be on one
of these hosted storage
systems-- which I
think is a great thing
about productivity--
really thinking about how
the features that are only
available in those platforms
could actually influence
the kinds of features
that you've built. So some of
the more interesting features
of Spanner, things
around BigQuery--
like, there's a lot
of things, that you
can do that are
really cool, that you
can't do on your laptop.
And that, I think,
would be great to think
about when you're designing
features in that product
you want to build.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, and
obviously the trade off there,
then, is this concept
of lock in, right?
If you were building stuff
with specific GCP features,
you get a lot of
value out of that,
but then you're sort of
tied to the platform.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, and I think
that's a trade off to make.
The way I think of it
is just, like, there's
a lot of different
features out there
and take advantage
of the best thing.
As much as like Cassandra
doesn't lock you
in in any way-- like,
there's a set of expertise
that we would have had
to build around that,
and that's an
investment there that we
would have to make if they
really wanted to do that.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah, and
then the bigger you get,
the more critical
about Cassandra
system is to your customers--
the more you have to
invest in making sure
that you have folks on staff
that can build it, manage it,
run it.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
So you're going
to make that investment
one way or the other.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, cool.
All right.
Well, thank you so much.
We really appreciate it.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Please
stay tuned for live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
less than a minute.
All right, welcome back.
Let's go through some
of our questions.
So first question we have is
around machine learning, right.
So are you considering to
using, kind of, machine learning
to improve some
of the information
that you're providing
to your users?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
This is a question we
get a lot actually.
Machine learning and
observability I think
is a really tricky thing.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Being wrong
in a way where you've woken up
an engineer at 3
o'clock in the morning--
oh, no, it wasn't a problem.
Sorry.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's right.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
It's pretty different,
and the confidence
that an engineer is
going to have in
that system is going
to go down really fast for
those kinds of false positives.
I think the way that we
think about LightStep
a lot is kind of as a guide.
So in other places where
we can use machine learning
to better surface the kinds
of facts and sort of evidence
that can help you
make a decision,
but really putting those
facts in front of you
for you, as a human to choose.
Because in the
end, like, you just
have state that
the machines don't
have, in terms of the where
that release has happened,
and sort of the organization,
how the software's developed,
all those kinds of things.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
and if you kind of
go back to things like
that-- [? sort of ?]
your principles, right?
The idea is that you want to
spend all the time upfront,
identifying your
SLOs, your SLIs.
And then when you're doing
things like alerting,
it's obviously
something that you've
designed very intentionally.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Exactly.
Exactly, yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
All right, so we started out
talking about microservices.
Did you build LightStep on
from using microservices?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
not from the beginning.
I think we started from a single
statically-linked go binary,
and that actually-- you
know, we actually still
have pieces of that
today, which, you know,
it's living on, and it's
sort of a continual challenge
in the place where
we have to invest
in our own infrastructure.
But yeah, I don't think--
I mean, as much as microservices
can be great in a lot of ways
if you were one person
sitting at your laptop,
microservices are about scaling.
They're about dividing
up your application
in a way that, like, maps into
your organizational structure,
right?
They're about fault isolation.
If you're running everything on
your laptop with you coding it,
like none of those things
are valuable, right?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: That's right.
And so, it's something you
have to have a lot of foresight
when you're first starting out,
so if you're literally just one
person building
on your laptop you
have to think about
what is my life
going-- if this thing
works, what is my life going
to be like a year from now?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
you have to think--
if you want to kind
of go down that route,
you have to be very
much forward thinking,
and it's hard to do that when
you're a person on your own.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, and there's
an investment in doing that,
because that slows things down.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah,
all of that is overhead.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: You've got
to deploy multiple services
before it was just a push
to [? scale ?] binary.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
All right, cool.
One more question I
think we have time for--
obviously, we've talked a lot
about what you're doing on GCP.
Are you running LightStep
in a multi-cloud way or not?
DANIEL SPOONHOWER:
Yeah, so part of it
does run today--
like, in that we
have those kind of
hybrid architecture.
So, you know, certainly
some of our customers
run parts of LightStep
on other Cloud providers.
They run it on bare metal--
on their own data centers.
And so, in some ways, we
actually feel kind of--
we get the advantages
and all of the pain
from running both on-prem
software and a SaaS solution.
But yeah, I think
as we move forward,
getting back to what we were
saying about lock in, you know,
I just see these
as opportunities.
So if there is places
where we can get value
by using a solution on a
different Cloud provider,
that's great.
Like, that's part of what
microservices really offers
as a way to build applications.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
All right, awesome.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
We really appreciate it.
DANIEL SPOONHOWER: Yeah,
no, it was a pleasure.
Thanks.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: All right.
Folks, please stay tuned
for the next session, which
is going to cover Google
Docs tips and tricks
to boost your productivity.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]